New Jersey spends a ton of money on
students why are the results not uh not
up to snuff but because we're spending
on all the wrong things like ridiculous
facilities right ridiculous you know
bells and whistles that we don't need
and the most important things like you
know breaking monopoly empowering people
with choice focusing on teacher quality
and compensation we don't do that stuff
we're focusing on doing it now but we
haven't done in the last 15 years what
would a widespread implementation of
opportunity scholarships for twenty or
forty thousand kids are all school kids
well you know what benefits would that
bring well so the most immediate one is
that it just gets a kid from a terrible
place to a great place and we can be
above everything that's what we want to
do but there are these longer-term
benefits that are financial that you
just can't ignore right i mean if you
can educate a kid for eleven thousand
dollars you don't have to spend twenty
five thousand dollars on them if you can
send a kid to a school that's already
got a facility you don't have to build a
new one and bond it out for 25 years in
the state that's already bankrupt so you
know the emotionally we're there from
policy standpoint we're there and
financially it's the best thing to do